اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي اصابه سته عسكريين
في معارك قطاع غزه خلال الساعات ال4
الماضيه وجاء في بيانات نشرها جيش
الاحتلال ان
2771 من ضباطه وجنوده اصيبوا منذ السابع
من اكتوبر الماضي واوضح الجيش الاسرائيلي
ان
1276 من هؤلاء العسكريين اصيبوا منذ بدء
الهجوم البري على قطاع غزه ويتلقى 00 188
عسكريا اسرائيليا العلاج اثر اصابتهم
بقطاع غزه
39 منهم اصاباتهم خطيره
و240 متوسطه و109 اصاباتهم
طفيفه ينضم الينا من غلاف غزه مراسل
الجزيره الياس كرام الياس اذا الاصابات في
ارتفاع ماذا عن جديد البيانات الاسرائيليه
وجديد تطور ورات الميدانيه
كذلك بالفعل والتحليق الكثيف للطيران
الحربي الاسرائيلي متواصل فوق المخيمات
الوسطى في قطاع غزه وسط قطاع غزه وهنالك
قصف مدفعي شديد ايضا بين الحين والاخر
يستهدف البريج والمغازي وال نصراط هذا
بالاضافه الى الغارات الجويه التي كانت
تستهدف هذه المناطق في الساعات الاخيره
نحن نشاهد هنا كما يبدو بعض التحركات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه من جانب الدبابات في
المناطق الشرقيه ل البريج هذا يبدو انه
توغل او تحرك للدبابات والاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه بالتجاه منطقه البريج فيما
يحلق الطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي بكثافه
فوق هذه المنطقه حقيقه منذ ساعات الصباح
وكان المعارك عادت لتشتت كما كانت عليه في
الاسابيع ال الماضيه بعد هدوء نسبي عم هذه
المنطقه تحديدا بعد انسحاب الفرقه 36 من
هذه المنطقه التي عملت فيها لكن الواضح
انه منذ ساعات الصباح هنالك قصف وان كان
قصفا مدفعيا متقطعا لهذه المناطق لكنه كان
يشتد حينا ويخف حينا اخر وكانت هنالك ايضا
غارات جويه كانت تستهدف مواقع كنا نشاهد
انها كانت تستهدف في الاسابيع الماضيه
وكان الجيش الاسرائيلي يضرب نفس نقطه
ويضرب نفس الاهداف في منطقه البريج وفي
منطقه المغازي وغيرها من المواقع الواقعه
في هذه المنطقه الوسطى لقطاع غزه اذا
نشاهد هنا كما يبدو في الصوره تحركا
عسكريا للاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه في
القاطع الشرقي في المناطق الشرقيه ل
البريج وهنالك ايضا كانت غارات جويه
استهدفت منطقه جحر الديك في الساعه
الاخيره بالاضافه الى قصف مدفعي اي على
هذه المنطقه بالتحدي حديد واذا ما اتجهنا
شمالا الى المناطق الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه
بعض المناطق الضواحي الجنوبيه للمدينه
والضواحى الغربيه تعرضت صباح هذا اليوم
لقصف جوي لغارات جويه متتاليه في بعض
الاحيان كان هنالك قصف مدفعي ايضا وفي
الساعه الاخيره كانت هنالك على الاقل غاره
جويه واحده طالت المناطق الجنوبيه الشرقيه
لمدينه غزه اذا هذا يوم اذا ما قارناه على
الاق قل في الايام القليله الماضيه هو
يشهد ضربات مدفعيه مكثفه يشهد غارات جويه
مكثفه هذا طبعا مقارنه مع الايام الماضيه
التي شهدت في بعض الاحيان في بعض الساعات
هدوءا نسبيا لا نقول بان المعارك قد انتهت
كليا وتوقفت كليا لكن مقارنه مع الايام
الماضيه هذا اليوم يشهد تكثيفا للضربات
المدفعيه وللغات الجويه تحديدا في جنوب
مدينه غزه وعلى وجه الخص خصوص في المناطق
الوسطى للقطاع هذا ينسجم مع ما كانت بعض
وسائل الاعلام العبريه قد تحدثت عنه
ونقلته عن مصادر في الجيش الاسرائيلي التي
قالت بان الجيش الاسرائيلي قد يضطر للعوده
للعمل بكثافه اكثر بكثافه ناريه اكثر
وربما بالتحرك ايضا عبر البر في عمليات
خاصه في المناطق الشماليه للقطاع على
اعتبار ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول بانه
لاحظ انه في المناطق التي انسحب من منها
او اعاد الانتشار منها في المناطق
الشماليه لقطاع غزه اثبتت المقاومه
الفلسطينيه انها قادره على العوده الى هذه
المناطق وملئ الفراغ وبالتالي كانت هنالك
ايضا بعض التنبيهات والتحذيرات من جانب
القياده العسكريه الاسرائيليه للمستوى
السياسي الاسرائيلي كما نقلت القناه الثان
الاسرائيليه وقالت بان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يعني اصدر بطاقه حمراء في وجه المستوى
السياسي في هذا المنحى وقالوا له بانهم
يريدون ان يعرفوا من هي الجهه التي ستتولى
المسؤوليه عن اداره قطاع غزه بعد انتهاء
الحرب او بعد انسحاب الجيش الاسرائيلي او
اعاده انتشار قواته في تلك ال المناطق على
اعتبار ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يلاحظ قدره
كبيره لدى المقاومه الفلسطينيه على العوده
الى ال معاقله الى السيطره الناريه في بعض
المواقع في مدينه غزه في المواقع الشماليه
على وجه الخصوص وربما يكون اكبر دليل على
ذلك هو وانه بعد ان قلل الجيش الاسرائيلي
من وجوده العسكري في الايام الماضيه منذ
مطلع العام الجديد تحديدا بعد ان سحب جنود
الاحتياط من كثير من المواقع في المناطق
الشماليه عادت المقاومه الفلسطينيه وضربت
اكثر من مره الصواريخ باتجاه منطقه غلاف
غزه باتجاه مدينه ديروت وبلدات صغيره اخرى
تحيط بها هذا بالاضافه الى القصف الصاروخي
الذي طال بالامس ايضا حتى الضواحي
الجنوبيه لمدينه عسقلان وه